Welcome to The Deep Dive. Today we are opening the black box of artificial intelligence in the workplace. Because, you know, every company on Earth has bought Gen-AI tools for their employees by now.
Oh, yeah. Everyone.
But almost nobody actually knows if their employees are any good at using them.
Right.
So our mission today is to answer that exact question. We're going to dig into a brand new, highly anticipated academic working paper to find out who actually knows what they're doing with these tools and why the current
approach to corporate training might just be completely broken.
Yeah, it's a fascinating look under the hood.
But before we get to the data, I want you to think about the corporate AI rollout kind of like this. It's a bit like a company buying everyone on staff a top of the line professional grade espresso machine for their desks.
Which, I mean, sounds like a very generous, highly caffeinated experiment.
Right. It does. And the procurement team checks the box. They look at their dashboard and they say, great, espresso machines deployed. We have 100 percent adoption.
Mission accomplished.
Exactly. But if you walk the floor and look at what people are actually doing, most people are just using this incredibly complex machine to dispense hot water for their tea. Yeah. They're using maybe 10% of its capability because no one actually taught them how to, you know, pull a shot,
dial in the pressure, steam the milk. Adoption is incredibly easy to measure. But skill, figuring out if anyone actually knows how to pull a good espresso, that has been a total blind spot.
It really has. It is the defining blind spot of this whole workplace technology wave. And that is exactly why this new working paper is so important. Yeah. It was just drafted recently, August 25, 2026. It's called Sophistication in Gen I
Use, Field Evidence from a Large Firm. And it's by Nicholas Hallman, Zachary Kowalewski, and Yemi Schmidt from the McComb School of Business, along with Anupu Vada from KPMG.
And we should just state really clearly right up front, this is a working caper. It's not yet peer reviewed. It was written by accounting and business school researchers who were granted data access by KPMG.
Right.
We aren't doing a deep dive on this because it's in some flashy journal. We're doing it because of the data.
Oh, totally. The data is genuinely rare.
Yeah.
Because until now, nearly every study of AI in the workplace has relied on one of three things.
Right. Like surveys.
Exactly. Surveys, which just tell you what people think they do. Or randomized trials of access, which basically just tell you if giving someone the tool helped them. Or you get platform-wide data from the vendors themselves.
Right, which has its own biases.
Yeah. But this paper, this paper has the actual raw chat transcripts from inside a single organization. And crucially, those transcripts are linked to each employee's seniority, their functional department, and their corporate training records.
Nobody else has had this combination.
Nobody.
Okay, let's unpack this because the scale is massive. We were talking about 713,564 user prompts. Wow. Yeah, across over 158,000 conversations. This involves almost 4,000 back office employees
across 15 different functional areas from January through August of 2025. It's
huge.
And they were using an internal tool called AIQ Chat, which routed them to commercial models like Anthropix, Claude 3.5 Sonnet, OpenAI's GPT-40 and 01, Google's Gemini, and Meta's Llama. So we finally have this
fly on the wall view of corporate AI use in the wild.
And the very first thing this fly on the wall sees is that adoption is solved, but skill is absolutely not. Right. This paper really reframes the whole AI at work conversation by showing this massive disconnect. If we go back to your espresso machine
analogy, the paper shows that 83.9% of employee months include the use of at least one AI tool.
Which is astronomical when you compare it to the national average. I mean, the BIC, Blandin, and Deming survey from around the same time showed only about 32% of U.S. workers reported using Gen AI for work.
Yeah.
So this firm is the absolute best case scenario. They bought it, they encouraged it, and they got near universal adoption.
Right. But that broad adoption masks an enormous, wildly skewed variation in how intensely people use it.
Okay. How skewed are we talking?
Well, the median active employee in this data set has just 14 conversations over an eight-month period.
Wow, that's practically nothing.
Right. Meanwhile, the top 10% of users account for 51% of all conversations.
So half the usage is coming from a tiny fraction of the workforce.
Exactly.
So if adoption is basically universal, but the actual usage is that concentrated, how do the researchers figure out who is actually good at it? Because, I mean, they obviously couldn't sit down and manually read 150,000 chat transcripts.
No, no, they couldn't. So they had to use AI to measure the AI use. Oh, of
course.
They define sophistication as skilled use, informed by an understanding of how the tool works and where it applies. So they fed every single transcript into an advanced large language model, OpenAI's O1, with a highly structured metaprompt.
Okay.
And they essentially asked the model to score the human's prompts and aggregate them into three composite measures of sophistication.
Let's break those three measures down because I think a lot of listeners will want to know if they themselves count as sophisticated users. So the first bucket is prompt clarity. Like, are they organizing their thoughts? Are they being specific?
Yes. And are they asking for structured output? For example, are they asking the AI to format the answer as a specific coding language like JSON or as a heavily formatted data table rather than just giving them a wall of text?
Got it. Okay. The second bucket is deliberate strategy use. And this is where we get into the heavy jargon of prompt engineering. They looked for things like role prompting, you know, saying act as a senior auditor. Right. But they also looked for few shot examples and chain of
thought. Wait, remind me really quickly so we don't lose anyone. What exactly are those two in practice?
Absolutely. So few shot examples just means you don't just ask the AI to do a task. You provide it with two or three completed examples of what good looks like first.
Oh, so it can spot the pattern.
Exactly. Chain of thought is when you explicitly ask the AI to show its work step by step before it gives you the final answer. It forces the model to reason through a problem, which dramatically reduces errors.
OK, that makes sense. And then the third bucket is use case diversity. So is this employee only using the AI as a glorified spell checker or are they applying it across a broad mix of tasks like analyzing data,
brainstorming, writing code?
Yeah, exactly. Now, I do have to inject a very important, honest caveat here.
OK.
The authors are extremely explicit about this. These three buckets are proxies for skill. They are measuring the quality and structure of the prompts themselves. Right. They are not measuring whether the employee actually got what they wanted or whether the
final output quality improved. We are measuring how well they operate the steering wheel, not whether they arrived at the correct destination.
That's a great point. But looking at how they operate the steering wheel is fascinating because the texture of real everyday work is just so vivid in this data. And honestly, the numbers are a little deflating.
Yeah, they really are.
Because writing dominates completely. Over 73% of conversations are just writing, mostly just editing text the user pasted in or generating new text. Knowledge queries are a distant second at 23%. Coding and data analysis all the way down
at 7%.
Which perfectly aligns with the background research we have from platform-wide data.
Right, right.
If you look at the Antropic Economic Index paper by Handa and colleagues, they mapped 4 million clawed conversations and found the exact same thing. Writing and software development dominate. The Handa paper shows us what the economy is doing with AI, but this Hallman paper shows us how
well individuals are doing it.
And the answer to how well is, well, it's pretty rough. Explicit constraints, like telling the AI exactly how long the response should be or what tone to use, that happens in only about 24% of chats. Requests for structured output, 2.9%.
Giving the AI explicit acceptance criteria so it can check its own work, 1%. It's
so low.
And those few shot examples and chain of thought requests we just talked about. Each of those appears in less than 1% of real workplace conversations.
The gap between the theoretical prompt engineering literature and actual desk work is just staggering. I mean, think about the Schulhof prompt report from 2024.
Oh, yeah, the taxonomy.
Yeah, that was a massive systematic survey that cataloged 58 distinct text-based prompting techniques. An entire research literature and a whole cottage industry of online courses was built around these 58 techniques.
And yet in the wild, any deliberate strategy at all only shows up 5.2% of the time. Exactly. But you know what does show up? Pleasantries. Yes. 30% of conversations include people saying please and thank you to the software. Nearly 11% of chats have frequent
typos. Over 5% are written entirely in lowercase letters.
It paints a very clear, very human picture of how casually people are interacting with these incredibly powerful systems.
Here's where it gets really interesting, though, because I look at that and my first instinct is, wow, the workforce is completely failing to learn how to use this tool. Right. But I have to push back on that a bit. Is it a failure of the workforce or is it a sign that the models have gotten
so good that all this complex 58 technique scaffolding just isn't needed anymore?
And that is the exact debate at the frontier of AI right now. We have to admit that this paper cannot fully settle it. Both interpretations are entirely valid. Maybe workers are leaving massive amounts of value on the table by not using those advanced techniques. Or maybe those techniques were just
temporary crutches for weaker models back in 2023. And by 2025, the models just understand what you want, even if you type it in all lowercase with typos.
Either way, the researchers did find clear patterns in who uses the tool with more sophistication, and their first major finding totally contradicts the conventional wisdom.
It really does. Because the standard narrative, the one every executive seems to believe, is that the digital native youth will naturally outperform their older, more senior colleagues with new tech.
But the data says the exact opposite. All three sophistication measures rise consistently step by step with seniority. Junior staff score the lowest, managers score higher, and above manager employees score the highest. Senior employees also use the
tools more often, and they use them for complex knowledge retrieval while junior staff skew heavily toward basic writing and personal requests.
We should bring in the Humlum Investor Guard study from 2025 here, which surveyed 18,000 Danish workers. Humlum found that younger workers adopt AI at much higher rates, and that every additional year of age predicted a lower likelihood of using the tool.
Wait, so how do those two things exist at the same time?
Because adoption and skill are not the same variable. Humlum proves that young workers adopt the tool more readily. But Humlum proves that older, more senior workers use it more skillfully.
OK, but wait, if senior people are better at it, how do we reconcile this with the famous 2025 study by Brynjolfsson, Lai and Raymond?
Ah, the AI as a leveler paper.
Right. They looked at customer support agents and found that AI boosted the productivity of novice low-skilled workers by 15%, while the highly experienced workers barely saw any benefit at all. Do these two papers just flat out contradict each other?
This is perhaps the most intellectually interesting tension in all of workplace AI research right now. But no, they don't contradict each other because they are measuring completely different environments. How so? Brynjolfsson looked at a very narrow, well-scoped tool built
specifically for customer support. It literally encoded the best agent's behavior into guidance for the new agent.
Oh, I see. So if I can use an analogy here, the AI in the Brynjolfsson study is like giving a novice driver a GPS on a set route. It tells the new driver exactly when to turn, which makes them perform almost as well as a local who has driven the roads for 20 years. But the GenAI chat interface
in the Hallman study, that's an open-ended, general-purpose tool. That's not a GPS. That's dropping a high-performance Formula One engine into a chassis on an open track.
Yeah, that's a perfect way to frame it.
A novice driver is just going to spin the tires. But an expert race car driver knows exactly how to tune it, how to push it, and how to get maximum performance out of it.
It is entirely coherent that AI lifts novices the most on routine tasks with known right answers. But sophisticated use of an open-ended gen AI tool requires domain expertise. Senior people are better at delegating.
They are highly practiced at specifying objectives, reviewing intermediate work, and pushing back to get exactly what they want because that is what their day job already is.
And they face more accountability for the final output. So they have a very real incentive to be precise.
Absolutely.
So sophisticated AI use might just be broad professional experience wearing a new hat. It's not necessarily a separate technical skill at all.
Exactly. Which explains their second big finding. Function matters just as much as seniority.
Meaning what department you're in.
Yeah, what your department does dictates how sophisticated your AI use is. Project management, strategy, and digital innovation all score significantly above the average on sophistication.
Which makes intuitive sense. I mean, project managers are constantly summarizing meetings, drafting timelines, synthesizing different streams of information. Those are tasks that an open-ended tech spot is amazing
at. Right. But the laggards in the data, this one hurts a bit given who provided the transcript.
Oh, no.
Accounting and finance scored below the mean on all three sophistication measures and below the mean on all usage categories inside a major professional services and accounting firm.
Oh, wow. Okay, but wait, we have to provide context here. The lesson is not that accountants are bad at AI.
No, no, it goes back to the workflow. A standalone text chat interface is simply a poor fit for spreadsheet-intensive, highly regulated, well-established accounting workflows.
Right. Accountants are all about structured data, formulas, and strict reconciliation. Trying to do complex financial math by typing paragraphs into a chatbot interface is incredibly frustrating and inefficient. The tool shape has to match the work's
shape.
Precisely. Other research, like the Troy and Xi paper, has shown that when Gen AI is built directly into the accounting workflow, rather than existing as the separate chat window, accountants actually see massive productivity gains.
OK, so if the tool doesn't naturally fit certain workflows and if junior staff are struggling to drive the Formula One engine, can we just train people to use it better? You would think so. But the data on corporate training is actually the most shocking part of this paper.
Yeah. This is finding number three, and it is the headline.
The static skill problem.
It's wild. Across the entire eight-month window of the study, the authors observe no genuine trend of sophistication rising. People are using the tool, but they aren't organically getting better at it over time.
And what's fascinating here is how the paper addresses the corporate AI training programs. When you look at the raw data, workers who took formal AI training provided by the firm look like they were using the tool in much more sophisticated ways.
Which sounds like a massive win for the HR department.
It does, until you look closer, because the researchers applied a statistical technique called employee fixed effects.
Right. Let's translate that for a second. What does that actually mean in practice?
It's a statistical trick that lets researchers track one specific person over time, stripping away outside factors. So instead of just comparing Bob who took the training to Alice who didn't, they look specifically at Bob's behavior before training compared to
Bob's behavior after training.
Oh, so it absorbs all of Bob's inherent personal traits like his natural ambition or his baseline tech savviness.
Exactly. And when they isolated the individuals like that, the truth emerged. Sophistication was higher only in the specific month the employee completed the training. The effect of past training is null. It just vanishes. The raw positive association
they initially saw was just selection bias.
So highly skilled, ambitious users are just the ones choosing to sign up for the training in the first place.
Yes. The training isn't producing the skill. The skilled people are just seeking out the training.
That is such a painful irony, because if we bring the Hunlund paper back in, in that Danish survey, workers explicitly reported that they felt held back by a perceived need for corporate training.
Yeah, they're practically begging for it.
But the field evidence here shows that standard corporate training leaves no lasting behavioral trace. We have to state this carefully, though, because the authors are very precise. Right. They don't say the training is entirely useless. It might provide a temporary top-of-mind boost,
or it might just capture employees trying out the new techniques during the week they learn them. But it does not produce a lasting change in how they interact with the AI.
So sending your staff to a two-hour prompting 101 seminar on a Tuesday isn't going to permanently transform them into AI whisperers. If standard training fails, how is a manager supposed to know who is actually good at this?
Because obviously, managers can't read 150,000 transcripts. Transcripts are expensive to process, and most firms don't even keep them for privacy reasons.
Which brings us to their fourth finding, which is highly practical. The authors look for cheap metadata signals, you know, things you can see on a basic IT dashboard that actually correlate with skill.
Okay, what do they look at?
They tested four constructs. Ambition, which is the length of the user's very first prompt. Persistence, which is how many rounds of back and forth iteration happen in a single conversation. Frequency, meaning how often they log in. And flexibility, whether they
also use other tools like Microsoft Copilot.
And which ones actually worked?
Consistently. Longer first prompts and more iteration track with more sophisticated use.
Okay.
Frequency and multi-tool use do not reliably predict it.
Let's contrast that with the Dillon study on Microsoft M365 Copilot from 2025. That randomized study showed that getting people to use the tool frequently was a major precursor to seeing productivity benefits. Workers who used it
regularly saved about half an hour a week on email.
And that highlights a crucial distinction for management. Getting people to use the tool more, which is what Dylan looked at, and getting them to use it better, which is what Hallman is measuring. Those are two completely different management problems.
Right.
Right now, most companies only have dashboards that measure logins and seat utilization. They're measuring frequency. And this paper proves that counting logins tells you almost nothing about skill.
OK, I have to play devil's advocate here for a second. I need to press the limits of this paper because the skeptical case against it is strong and our listeners are smart enough to spot the holes.
Bring it on.
First of all, it's just one firm. It's a professional services firm. Yes, back office functions like HR and marketing exist everywhere, but it's still a specific corporate culture.
That is a very fair limitation.
Second, it's entirely descriptive, not causal. And as we discussed earlier, this sophistication measure is literally just an LLM's opinion of a human's prompt. We have zero proof that the final accounting report or marketing email actually got better or was done
faster.
Also
true. But here is my biggest pushback. The window for this data closed in August 2025. In the AI world, that is ancient history. By the author's own admission, models have advanced massively since then. We have autonomous
agents now that act on our behalf. Does studying prompting behavior from mid-2025 tell us anything useful as we sit here in late 2026?
I will absolutely hold the line on this one because the data is still unprecedented. Yes, the models have evolved, but human habits evolve much, much slower. That's true. Behaviors, cognitive approaches to delegation, and the sheer ability to articulate a clear goal, those are human skills, and they outlast any
single generation of a software model. Documenting this point in time is how we establish a baseline at all. Before this, we were just guessing based on surveys.
So what does this all mean? The conversation around AI at work has been entirely stuck on adoption. Did we buy the tool? Did we turn it on? This deep dive looks at what happens after adoption is finished. And the answer is
pretty uncomfortable.
Yeah, it is.
Skill is highly concentrated in a small group of super users. It cracks almost perfectly with the professional experience people already had. It didn't organically grow over eight months. And it stubbornly resisted standard corporate training intervention.
Which forces us to really question that optimistic utopian narrative from the Brynjolfsson paper. The idea that AI is going to do this great leveler that instantly boosts the junior staff and compresses the inequality gap in the office, well, that doesn't
obviously survive contact with the general purpose tool on open-ended work.
Right. If sophisticated AI use really is just domain expertise wearing a new costume, then these tools might actually widen the gap between the senior experts and the junior novices rather than closing it.
And that raises an important, frankly chilling question to leave you with today. If driving an AI well requires deep, hard-won domain expertise, but the AI is simultaneously being used to automate away the exact entry-level junior work
where that expertise used to be built, where exactly do the next generation of senior experts come from?
That is definitely something to mull over on your next coffee break. Thanks for joining us on this deep dive. We'll see you next time.